une conférence au cours de laquelle la
russie et la turquie ont joué
l'apaisement hier après une série de
déclarations agressives au sujet de la
syrie
les relations entre les deux pays se
sont tendues ces derniers jours
notamment en raison de la progression de
l'armée syrienne dans la région d'idlib
le point avec théo combres la poignée de
main est chaleureuse les sourires de
mise
les multiples piques verbales entre
ankara et moscou semble oubliée pourtant
le début de semaine fut agitée entre les
deux capitales
après la mort de 14 soldats turcs dans
des bombardements orchestrée par les
forces de bachar al assad
des combats meurtriers qui ont vu
turquie et russie s'oppose et par voie
de presse interposée durant la semaine
la raison de cette montée des tensions
la progression de l'armée arabe syrienne
soutenues par le kremlin
vers la ville d'idlib au nord ouest du
pays une cité en partie contrôlé par des
milices qui sont pour la plupart des
alliés d'ankara
une situation qui a mis en lumière les
différences de stratégie entre les
présidents recep tayyib erdogan et
vladimir poutine des divergences qui ne
remettent pas en cause les relations
russo turque selon les ministres des
affaires étrangères des deux pays avec
la turquie nous avons de très bonnes
relations
on peut pas être d'accord sur tout et je
pense pas que deux pays peuvent avoir
à un accord parfait sur tous les points
sinon ça ressemble un peu à une pression
qui a été organisée les différences
d'opinion série ne doivent pas affecter
les relations turco russe la situation à
église n'affectera pas l'accord sur les
s 400 une situation qui inquiète les
occidentaux comme l'a signifié le
ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères et ico masse nous avons aussi
parlé de la situation en syrie adib nous
sommes très préoccupés par ce qui est en
train de devenir une catastrophe
humanitaire si les combats ne s'arrête
pas j'ai déjà demandé à mon homologue
russe d'utiliser son influence sur le
régime d'assad pour que ces attaques et
ces combats cessent et c'est pourquoi
j'espère que les prochains pourparlers
entre la russie et la turquie la semaine
prochaine se traduiront par des progrès
dans ces domaines afin que nous soyons
épargnés d'une autre catastrophe
humanitaire là bas une délégation turque
doit en effet se rendre à moscou lundi
pour évoquer le sujet pour rappel
l'offensive actuelle de damas sur id
libre ap plus de 800 mille déplacés
depuis décembre selon l'onu